There's no one who has not been affected by this.
Jeffrey, what's going on?
I don't have a clue.
Is anybody there, can anybody hear me?
Guys, we got 32 elevators off the grid, all the upper floors are gone.
Can anybody hear me?
Metzie, it's Eddie.
Baby, you're not gonna believe this.
Hello?
Oh, mom!
Where the hell are you?
We're still in the north tower.
Can you please have her call my wife?
Me too.
Mom, listen to me.
Hello?
When something tragic happens, your heart and your soul...
...latch onto what really matters.
You don't know me, I'm calling you for your husband...
...he wanted you to know that he loves you.
It's a story about really honoring those that didn't make it...
You gotta get out of this building now!
...and those that did.